I can't either.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
continuing.
injed
regarding the of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
and the levels
and virtues of the of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
and also
a description of the various ious types
of shik that which will invalidate a
person's tohe
the greatest act of worship
that any human being can produce
is the of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
worshiping Allah alone without any
partners
now this may seem a given as we are
Muslim And our religion revolves around
the oneness of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
However,
as we've mentioned before,
the
paganism and the idolatry
of those previous nations that came
before us,
that preceded us.
They were built and based on an entire
foundation of belief.
And this foundation of belief permeated
their environment, permeated their way
of life, their thought,
their minds,
and they saw the world through the
worship of their idols.
And so many superstitions, many beliefs,
many
fables and tales and mythologies
have worked their way into the human
being's life. And the only way a person
would notice these things and recognize
them for what they are and be able to
reject them from their life. And for an
individual to be able to clean his life
and his actions and his heart from
anything that would partially or
entirely
negate their
is by learning the
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in its
various forms and learning that which
will
that which will negate a person's to
heat.
A person will only fully understand a
concept once they have conceptualized
its opposite.
And so, for instance, in order for a
person to fully appreciate what daytime
is, they must also learn what nighttime
is. This will complete their knowledge
of that.
Likewise, for a person to fully
understand
what
toed is, they must also study all those
things that will negate their
those things which are of a shik and its
major forms and its minor forms and its
most subtle forms. The prophet
sallall.aii Wasam
told Abu Bakr.
He said
that the types of shik and the
subtleties of shik
are more discreet are more are found to
be more discreet. in my nation than the
footsteps of an ant on granite.
Meaning, if you're not looking for it
and listening for it, you will not see
it.
There are many superstitions
that the mushrian
of the ancient Arabs had. The pagans and
polytheists of ancient Arabia had many
superstitions
which are startlingly
comparable and similar to the
superstitions in modern day that people
have.
So for instance, a Muslim
will not bow down and worship an idol
for sure, even the most ignorant of
Muslims. However,
what about the other subtle
nuanced
types of shik that occur
such as the shik of a charm, a lucky
charm. This is a type of shik or the hor
horoscopes.
Whoever's born in this month and this
will happen. Whoever's born in this
month and this will happen. This is all
a type of shik.
Likewise,
the acts of the s suit soothsayers in
likewise,
which is using things as a charm for
luck
or
using things to ward off evil spirits.
And we hear this often.
for instance one of the beliefs in
ancient Arabia
was that when a person is murdered and
they die quote unquote before their
time, this is what they believed.
Then that person's soul would haunt the
place that they were killed in until
justice is received. until until justice
has been had.
And so they believed in hauntings
and that these hauntings were the result
of violent deaths.
Tell me in our modern society here in
America,
all cases of hauntings or most of them
are believed to be a result of what
there were. You know, you you hear these
stories. A person goes, they buy a
house, a family buys a house, they find
that the house is haunted.
So, the house is haunted. What caused
this haunting? Well, they research into
the history of the house and they find
out that there was some kind of violence
that took place there and some people
lost their life there. And now that old
man who, you know, had this thing happen
to him in the house, he is still roaming
the hallways of his home waiting to be
released into the afterlife. Right? This
is all part of the shik of the mushik of
ancient Arabia. It's not specific to the
ancient Arabia. This is something that a
shaitan whispers into the hearts of men
from the inception.
Or for instance
there is a particular tree or a
particular grave
and if you or a particular toy
some kind of you know some kind of
teddy bear or action figure and this is
a haunted toy
and if you go and take the toyy's
picture without its permission
bad things will happen in your life. I'm
not making this up. This exists right
now here in America. This is very
well-known case. There are hundreds of
people who have posted their stories
about I went to visit this toy
and I took its picture without asking
permission.
And since then I lost my job. My wife
left me. My dog ran away, right? my
truck
through a piston,
my I keep getting flat tires, right?
Whatever. And hundreds of people write
apology letters to the toy
asking for its forgiveness. Please
forgive me and allow me to live my life
again. I shouldn't have had such bad
manners with you. Right? This is one
instance of many.
And so what kind of shik is this? This
is a type of shik which is major shik in
Islam.
Major shik meaning that a person fears
other than Allah
with a fear that is only for Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
This is not minor shik. This will
invalidate a person's Islam entirely.
A person fears other than Allah is going
to afflict him with something only Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala can do. This is one
example of many.
So much so that the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam prohibited that a person
worship Allah in a place where idols
were worshiped
or that they worship Allah with a type
of worship that idols are worshiped
wherever they had a holiday of shik etc.
So the rulings of are very vast and very
numerous.
For this reason the prophet sallall.aii
Wasam
spent 13 years at the beginning of his
teaching the companions
the various types of and shik that which
will invalidate a person's
that which will partially or entirely
negate
a person's and Islam
when we speak about the invalidation.
When we speak about a person's Islam
becoming invalid,
a person's Islam can become invalid
entirely
or a person's Islam could become invalid
partially.
And so that which entirely invalidates a
person's Islam is major major kufur. And
that which partially invalidates a
person's Islam invalidates a portion of
their Islam
are the various types of shik that come
from the superstitions
of the mushri.
And so when the prophet sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam was sent to the people
of Arabia and sent to mankind
in the ancient Arabia. He came upon a
people that were enveloped
and engrossed
in superstition and the worship of other
than Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And it had permeated every facet of
their lives,
even the way that they viewed the
wildlife,
the way that they viewed the months and
the years.
You cannot get married on a particular
date. You should not it is not good
to travel on a particular date. This
particular road is haunted or ominous.
This particular
valley is a place that
a person cannot go to at particular
times.
That a person should not marry during
the month of Rajab.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam was sent and was sent to
deliberately break these superstitions.
So for instance they believed that it
was ominous for a person and bad luck
for a person to get married
during the month of Rajab.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam married Zanab during the month
of Rajab.
They believed that if a person were to
get married on a particular time or in a
particular way, this would cause the
failure of the marriage.
And even today,
many customs that the Muslims have
adopted follow this line of
superstition.
So for instance where I come from
if a person
it's very distracting
this is not a time to talk right to
listen please
[Arabic recitation]
distracting to me and everyone else
police.
And so where I come from, one of the
superstitions
is that if you go to get married,
you cannot fold your hands while you're
getting married.
You have to sit with your hands out like
this while the marriage is being
conducted.
If you fold your hands, the marriage is
going to be stricken with bad luck. As
if marriage is an issue that keeping
your hands open they'll even tell
me I'm doing your hands are folded. Open
your hands. What's in my hands? How is
this going to affect a person's marriage
or that a person should get married
during Ramadan
or the 27th of blah blah blah all of
this is called considered to be a type
of what type of shik this will
invalidate a p a part of a person's
Islam doesn't make them a disbeliever
however it is a type of shikah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
Or
if you hear an owl
at night over your house, someone in the
house is going to die.
This is taken directly from the mushri
of ancient Arabia. Exactly.
Or
if there is a ghost that's going around
and humbugging the village, you need to
take salt and put it on the window sills
and across the doorways
so that the ghost is not able to come
into your house.
or such and such tree
cannot be cut down or interfered with at
all
because that tree belongs to such and
such and if you interfere with it you
will be you know afflicted with cancer
or and then they have all kinds of
stories about it to the point where this
will even become a national thing.
Imagine in modern society in some
eastern airlines there is no row number
13.
There is no 13th floor. It goes 1214.
There's no 13th floor. Why? Because 13
is an ominous number.
7 is a lucky number.
So this is all what? This is all part of
a shik that the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam was sent to rid from the
hearts of humanity.
The prophet sallall.aii Wasallam was
once asked in the narration of
he was once asked about
what are
you go to the person and they start to
tell you about your future or tell you
about something that will occur or tell
you about your mother's maiden name that
only your cousin Bob knows about and
then people start to fear this person
and believe this person. The prophet
sallall.aii wasallam was asked about
and so he said
these people are a non- entity nothing.
This is a major thing to say. Why?
Because in the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam's time magicians were paid our
equivalent of millions of dollars. And
they were feared by people.
And so they asked him, "Sallam,
sometimes
they tell us something and it actually
happens."
And so the prophet sallall.ai Wasam
explained how the that work with these
soothsayers
stack on top of each other to listen in
on the
rulings and discussions of the heavens.
And sometimes they are able to bring
back a single thing that they overheard.
And in doing so, the magician or
soothsayer will then add 99 lies on top
of it and then tell it to their
customer.
They believed in the time of ancient
Arabia that there were things called al
where I come from they call it a is a
type of jin that is a devil and it
shapeshifts and it takes people astray
in the desert
right etc. All of these superstitions
are what will invalidate or
nullify a portion of a person's Islam.
They will meet Allah with a heart that
is diseased with superstition and shik
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala tells our
messenger Sai Wasam
Tell them, tell the people, tell your
followers, tell your nation the stories
of those who have preceded them in order
that they may contemplate
said stories.
One of the great blessings of the Quran
is that Allah Subhanahu Waaala
tells us the most critical stories
throughout humanity's existence
from the inception and the creation of
Adam
up until our messengers time and even
stories that have not yet occurred.
that will occur in the future. These are
the most critical stories. They're not
legends. They're not fables. They're not
contrived
contrived kind of metaphorical
fables. These are stories of real men
and real women. stories to be taken
literally
in order for us to contemplate
and to understand what it is that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala desires of us
and what it is that a shan desires of
us.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
has said
tell them then the stories
in order that they may contemplate
contemplate said stories
and learn to apply those stories to
their individual and general lives.
One of these stories is a narration that
was collected by Bkari and Muslim
on the authority of
he tells us of an incident that occurred
in which a man wished
to
repent to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala for
his wrongdoing.
And the story of that repentance
and how a person's intention
and a person's
strong will and desire to do good will
carry him through to the hereafter and
the mercy of Allah even if they are
unable to complete that good that they
set out to do.
Abu
narrates that the messenger of Allah.
Wasam said,
for
[Silence]
narrates that the prophet sallall.aii
Wasam said there was a man in the
previous nations meaning amongst Bi is
a man who had murdered 99 people.
He had taken 99
souls.
Murdered 99 people.
Why did he murder them? How did he
murder them? Aloha. It is
inconsequential
how he got to that junction, but somehow
he managed to swallow all of the
darkness of his time and arrive at 99
innocent souls that he had murdered.
However, after all of this darkness
and after all of this disobedience,
in spite of that, he felt a tinge of
remorse that drove him to ask about the
most knowledgeable person available.
He went he asked the people, the people
of righteousness. He went to wherever
the people of Allah reside and he asked
them, I have a very important question.
I would you to direct me to the
most knowledgeable person on earth
that you know of. Direct me to someone
because I have a very critical question.
And so the people directed him
to a raid.
They directed him to someone who was a
righteous man, a man that loved Allah, a
man that was in constant worship of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. But he was
confused with being a scholar. He was
not a scholar. He was just a righteous
man. A rahib
a rahib is someone who is akin to a monk
not a person of knowledge.
And so he went to this man thinking that
he this man is speaking on behalf of
Allah
and he asked him
that he has killed 99
people.
Is there any way that he could repent?
Is there any hope for such a wretched
soul?
And so this rahib this monk out of his
ignorance said, "No,
there is no repentance
for such an atrocity."
And so the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said the man then killed him and
completed 100
Now he's got a hundred under his belt.
One of which we know was a righteous
man.
Notice how ignorance
in Allah's religion is a disease amongst
the Muslim.
Look at the violence that is unleashed
because of ignorance.
This man came seeking redemption. was
not given an exit, was not given a way
to repent. And so this unleashed his
violence.
And that potential tells us that look
how ignorance takes a people astray.
This ignorance occurred way before he
came to ask the monk. This ignorance
occurred amongst the people of Benisel
who could not differentiate between a
scholar and a man of ignorance. They
could not differentiate between a
scholar and a monk.
They thought that this monk was a
scholar. They see him all the time
praying and worshiping Allah. They see
him all the time. They he reminds them
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
maybe he would command the good and
forbid the evil. And so people started
to believe that this was a scholar.
So when the time came for a scholar,
this man was good enough.
And so what happened?
Violence was unleashed.
It resulted in his death. And it could
have been much worse
because
hopelessness
is one of the greatest tools that a shan
uses to drive people into the flames of
hell.
When a person feels hopeless,
when they feel there's no chance
for them, there's no way to redeem
themselves,
they've gone too far, when they feel
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's door is
closed in their face.
This is when humanity at large suffers
because the only thing that will keep a
human being on the right track. The only
thing is not surveillance,
is not a bloated huge government that is
in every facet of their lives watching
them to make sure that they're following
the law.
It is not constant policing.
The only thing that will save humanity
from itself is their fear and love and
hope in Allah.
Nothing else.
And when a human being loses hope in
Allah, whether it's because they don't
believe in his existence,
whether it's they believe that they have
no chance of redemption,
whatever it is, when the human being
becomes hopeless, violence, misery, and
tragedy will ensue invariably.
And so this man when this other
individual came he said I have I killed
99 people.
99 people. We're not speaking about you
know one incident or two incidents or he
was a pilot. We're speaking about one at
a time. 99.
Is there any way that I can repent? This
man was a man of ignorance
because he looked at this sin as being
too great even for Allah's forgiveness,
even for Allah's mercy. It was too much.
So all those years of worship, what was
he really worshiping during that time?
He was worshiping something that he
believed that superimposed
on Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And so 99 souls that he took, it's
possible that he knew of him. Maybe he
was a known criminal.
And so he came and asked, "Is there any
hope for me?" He said, "No, if there's
no hope for me, I really don't you
either." And so he killed him and
completed a hundred.
This is why scholarship is so dire.
Not just in the world, not just amongst
the Muslim one or two in a country.
Scholarship is absolutely critical in
every single masid in every community.
There has to be men who are able to
guide the people to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
Men who have inherited from the prophet
sallall.aii wasam.
Those who remind the people when they
forget.
Those who are awake when the people are
asleep.
Those who cry when the people laugh. And
those who smile when things seem
hopeless because of their knowledge of
Allah.
The prophet sallall.aii
said,
he said, "The virtue that a scholar
holds over a monk is the virtue
that the moon holds over the rest of the
stars in the sky."
The prophet sallall.aii Wasam said that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala does not take
knowledge back from a people by
extracting it from the hearts of men.
[Silence]
He said rather Allah takes knowledge
from a people through the death of the
scholars
and the scholars will continue to become
more and more scarce until the people
cannot find a scholar to lead them. They
will then hence take an ignorant man in
place of a scholar.
These ignorant men will then be asked
and they will then speak on behalf of
Allah and they will go astray and lead
the people astray with them. This is the
danger.
The prophet sallall.aii
said,
"Whomever Allah desires good for, he
will grant him or them understanding of
the religion."
Understanding
that is for individuals and communities
and countries and entire nations.
If Allah desires good for them, he will
place amongst them men who fear Allah
and who know Allah, who are scholars,
who are heirs of Muhammad sallall.aii,
they will then lead the people to the
path of Allah.
However, if Allah does not desire good
for a people, he will allow them to take
the ignorant as leaders,
they will then speak on behalf of Allah.
They will go astray and take others
astray with them.
There is this kind of misconception
that many of us have
that I don't really have to know that
much. What's really the difference
between a scholar and a layman? Not that
much. As long as I have really, really
good intentions,
I can think my way to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. That's not how it works.
There's no difference between that
person and a person who says that he can
accidentally build a skyscraper
or he can accidentally
build a Ferrari from scraps engine
purring door open.
That's not how it works. A person
doesn't stumble into the grace of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. It's not an
accidental thing.
This is something that is deliberate.
You must know that the door is there
before you can knock on it. There's no
other way.
And a person of knowledge
holds in his heart an exaltation of
Allah that cannot be had with ignorance.
There are men
even amongst the companions
who prayed who prayed more than Abu Bakr
and Omar who even
number-wise maybe even prayed more than
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam. But
will their prayer ever ever be the
prayer of Abu Bakr and Omar or the
prophet sallall.aii Wasam.
He tells us that the best of fasting is
the fasting of dood. And the best of
prayer is the prayer of dood. He used to
fast one day and break his fast the
next. Our prophet didn't do that. He did
a third of that. Yet he is the im of the
mut and doud is one of his many many
followers amongst the messengers. Why?
What's the difference? It's not an issue
of quantity.
It is an issue of quality.
It's a diamond. You cannot rush
that process. It comes as a result of
very very very specific conditions
and those conditions have to be met.
Only then can a diamond be produced.
Only then can a pearl be produced and
only by a clam. Only by weight and
pressure and friction can a diamond be
produced. It's not an accidental
process.
The prophet sallall.aii
Wasam said, "Allah came to me in my
sleep."
And he asked me, "Do you know what the
greatest of angels compete with one
another over?" I said, "No."
He said,
[Silence]
He said
that Allah asked him, "Do you know what
the highest ranking angels compete in?"
I said, "No."
He said, "Sall." Wasam.
Allah then placed his hand between my
shoulder blades and I felt the coolness
come up between my in my chest in the
center of my chest and I was shown that
which is in the heavens and that which
is in the earth Ibraimisam
was shown.
How can you compete with that kind of
knowledge? Our prophet sallall.aii Wasam
makes two with that heart. All of us
combined cannot compete with that.
There is no way to the high levels of
grace
with Allah except by way of knowledge.
And knowledge is not something that can
be had overnight.
It's not information. A few Google
searches and you know there's a
difference a difference between
knowledge and facts and information.
Just you cannot accidentally
build an engine you likewise cannot
accidentally build a relationship with
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. This man,
even though he had just murdered this
monk, and even though he was more
ignorant or supposed to be than this
monk, he still asked again,
"I would you to direct me to the
most knowledgeable man."
And so this time he was directed to a
scholar. He still had hope.
Even though that monk was hopeless.
Imagine being so ignorant that a
murderer, a serial killer has more good
thoughts about a love than a monk who
spends his days and nights in worship.
But that is the confusion and the
delusion of ignorance. And so this time
he was directed to a scholar
and he asked him, "He has killed 100
men.
Is there any hope for him to repent?"
The scholar quickly said,
he said, "Of course." And what is
standing between you and repentance? For
who could stand between you and
repentance? No man.
And then he directed him to go to a land
outside of his environment. He said,
"There's a people there. Go there. Make
that hij that migration. Be with them
and do not come back here because this
is an evil place. And if you return
here, you will return to your ways." The
scholar didn't just give him yes, you
can repent and sent him on his way. He
gave him a detailed prescription.
And so the man set off to the righteous
land.
And on his way, he died at exactly the
halfway point.
The prophet sallall.aii
Wasam said, "The angels of mercy and the
angels of punishment and torment then
descended simultaneously
and started to debate as to who is more
rightful to this man's soul."
The angels of mercy said he was on his
way to repent. The angels of punishment
said, "He has never done a good deed.
He's never done any good in his life.
This man is a nuisance to society.
The angels of punishment were looking
back to where he came from. The angels
of mercy were looking forward to where
he was going.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
commanded them to measure the distance
between him and the two lands and to
whichever of those lands he was closer
he is to be of its people.
The prophet Sam
said,
[Silence]
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
said Allah told and commanded the path
behind him to shrink and the path in
front of him to grow or the path in
front of him to shrink and the path
behind him to grow
just a handspan just enough for his
scales of good to outweigh his scales of
evil.
And so the angels of mercy took him.
Imagine how much Allah reaches out back
to you. When you try to reach out to
him, he will change the earth
and he will change the laws of physics
in order to include you into the people
of paradise.
Our prophet sallall.aii Wasam has said
that Allah himself has said
[Silence]
he said subhanahua that if my servant
reaches out to me a handspan I will
reach out to him a cubit. And if he
reaches out to me a cubit, I will reach
out to him an arms length. And if my
servant comes to me walking, I come to
him running.
This is the mercy of Allah. We have all
done bad things. There is not one
innocent man amongst us. Not one
innocent man or woman amongst us.
However, what is our hope? Our hope is
not in ourselves.
It's not in believe in yourself, love
yourself so that you all these oneliners
that are useless in practical life.
It is believe in Allah, find all your
hope with Allah.
And if a person reaches out ever so
slightly, Allah will scoop him up. Allah
will include him amongst the people of
mercy.
Allah says, "What does Allah want with
your punishment if you are thankful and
believe?" And indeed Allah is thankful
and all knowing. Allah has described
himself to us as thankful. Imagine that.
Imagine Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is of
such generosity
that he will give you
that which you can worship him with. He
will then be pleased with you and he
will then praise you for what he gave
you in the first place. How can a per
how can generosity ever reach such
heights?
This is our
There is not one of us here who is
innocent. But there is not one of us
here who is hopeless. Not one of us.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Allah
All
[Silence]
for
Allah.
[Silence]
Allah. foreign.
All
becommen.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillahb.
There we go.
Stand shouldertosh shoulder. Take a
moment to look to either side. Make sure
that your feet and your shoulders are as
in line with your two neighbors as
possible. The coherence of the rose and
the straightness of the rose is a large
part of what we are judged upon when our
prayer is accepted by Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
Please take a moment to check your
phones. Make sure that they are silent.
foreign.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
Amen.
I'm just
for
[Silence]
Love
me. Allah
holy man.
[Silence]
Allahel.
Alhamdulillah.
Fore!
Foreign! Foreign!
for him.
Amen.
[Silence]
Happy
send me Allah.
You
alone.
[Silence]
Allahel.
Allah
out.
[Silence]
assalamu alaykum.
Brothers and sisters, asalam alaikum.
Couple of quick announcements. First the
for tomorrow inshallah will be 5:45 a.m.
again tomorrow morning 5:45 a.m. The
youth halaka today is after m inshallah
and Quran classes just want to see
everybody is no is aware of this we need
some attention to that it's from 11 to
100 p.m. that's tomorrow that's every
Saturday 11 to 1:00 p.m. There's Quran
classes. There's a separate class for
the for the girls and se another one for
the boys. So please in participate in
that and see if your children can
benefit from it. One other thing I'd
to mention and I think people may
have been just concerned about some of
this is there is no fee for these things
any of the classes that Masid offers. So
if there is any question about the the
dues or anything, please talk to me or
brother Ahmed Jabar and at least make
sure even for the Rama Academy we have
the programs available to take care of
your needs. So please make sure that you
are available
and at least give a child your children
opportunity to learn the deen inshallah
and benefit from the academy. Please
donate generously on the way out.
Hey. Hey. How you doing?